Welcome to iOS development.
I'm Rod, and I'm going to be
your instructor for this course.
In the first part of this course,
we're going to build an app that
let's you record your voice and
play it back with sound effects.
This course assumes you're familiar
with basic programming concepts,
like if statements, loops and classes.
You don't need to have written any iOS
apps, or any experience with Swift.
We'll cover everything you need to
know as you go through this course.
Developing for iOS is a lot of fun.
You get to write apps that you
can carry right in your pocket.
Let's start by looking at the steps
we'll take to build this app.